[Music]
after ant-man asked the question you
ever watch Iron Man but small marbles
played a solo movie invite you to ask
another you ever watch Iron Man on weed
Doctor Strange experienced the grand
illusion that you haven't seen this
movie before as you sit through the
heroic origins of a cocky but capable
super rich wisecracking
workaholic with a weird goatee in love
with a redheaded subordinate learning to
be less selfish played by a famous
Sherlock Holmes actor it's like Iron Man
but actually that's it it's pretty much
just like Iron Man Magic has come to the
Marvel Universe and not that it's just
science BS that Thor went on about your
ancestors called it magic and you call
it science we're talking acid trips 70s
blacklight poster magic that bend space
and time and new plot breaking ways and
uses mind-blowing effects to distract
you from the fact that the action is
still 90% punchy shouldn't that hurt his
hands you cringed when he tried to do a
southern accent power didn't go out I
forgot to set the clock I'm sorry mom
you weren't sure if he was serious when
he attempted a Boston one-in-a-lifetime
good to see you doing so well now
Benedict Cumberbatch will sound like an
English man pretending to be a German
man pretending to be an American in a
feature-length tribute to Hans Gruber's
accent and die hard when he gets caught
by Bruce Willis
[Music]
you care so much don't see Benny Bubbe
your natural voice is perfect use it
joining the titular strange on his
journey from act 1 protagonist to act
three protagonists are side characters
and villains who are up to the usual
Marvel standard chiwetel ejiofor who's
just kind of there to explain things
temporary manipulations can create
branches in time this is a relic the
sanctums protect the world and we
sorcerers protect the sanctums
Mads Mikkelsen playing a bad guy with
weird eyes for the third time in his
career whose entire plan revolves around
successfully ripping some pages out of a
book to summon a malevolent demon who he
hopes won't enslave the human race not a
great plan
tilda swinton a being of immense power
bravely guarding the Marvel Cinematic
Universe from Asian actors whose Celtic
and this club with more personality than
any of the human beings stop pad I want
to see that cloak crossover with the rug
and Ladin so bad
enjoy a visual masterpiece that has to
be seen in 3d on a giant screen to be
fully appreciated because when you watch
it on a laptop you realize just how much
of it is medical mumbo-jumbo you need to
get a prep for suboccipital craniotomy
confusing transected spinal cords I'm
stimulating neurogenesis in the central
nervous system pass a stent down the
brachial artery under the radial artery
to complete c7 c8 spinal cord injury
with a heaping side order of magic mumbo
jumbo the documents and makes them more
powerful in the Murrah dimension saw the
rich wasn't a prokaryote shrine I pushed
your astral form out of your physical
form the wand of watoomb
the vaulting boots about or hazy second
semester ritual to contact the mama when
you draw power from the dark dimension
Wingardium Leviosa me sideways this is
unnecessary
just shoot laser beams out of your wand
and be done with it
so enjoy a film that despite its faults
doesn't fall into the third act trap of
battling a CGI army and a sky being
saves money by replaying the same scene
13 times in a row and sends a powerful
message to the children modern medicine
can't be trusted my spirit deepened and
somehow the party healed yes and don't
text and drive because you might in
attorney into a wizard starring Benedict
Wong Benedict white Bordeaux Morpheus
you Mads bro night nurse circle hands
hands-on hands on hands on hands on
hands on hands and Ricky Bobby hands
[Music]
I'm not sure what to do with my hand
stranger things
so Cumberbatch did the motion capture
for Dormammu himself man he really likes
to goof around leotards huh none can
stop me hey screen junkies hollywood's
hottest daughter isn't done with you yet
click the box on the left to watch
Benedict Cumberbatch answer our silly
questions in our honest interview or
click the Box on the right to see where
our cumber crush began in the honest
trailer for Sherlock and please stop
yelling at us about aluminum we get it
Dormammu I come to bargain Dormammu I
come to bargain Dormammu I come to
bargain Dormammu I'd come to bargain
Dormammu I'd come to bargain